Let's go ahead and start with the endpoint.
It's simply a Wikipedia URL with a search string put inside.
So far so good.
Then we come to the AJAX request object.
We start off by creating a URL parameter and
setting it equal to the wikiUrl that we just created.
If we didn't want to pass the URL in as a parameter of this object,
it could actually just be a string by itself that comes before this settings
object inside this method call.
In other words, we could've passed the URL in here as a string before
the settings object instead of making it a parameter of the settings object,
but either way works.
Then we set the data type to jsonp, indicating that this a JSONP request, and
then we have a success function.
I've got a line commented out here for
JSONP as a parameter, setting JSONP to callback.
Some APIs want to use a different name for the callback function.
By default, using JSONP as a data type
will set the callback function name to callback.
So this line here's actually redundant.
But if we needed to change it in other words if we
needed to change this callback right here.
In that case we would use a different string here on the JSONP property.
Check the instructor notes for more on JSONP.
Inside the success parameter we've got this anonymous function which is run when
we get the response.
Let's take a look at this response in the browser.
Inside the network tab we can see this request for
Wikipedia, let's click on it, and it looks like we've got a JavaScript object.
Like we said before,
this JavaScript object is going to be wrapped within a function.
So, we can see this long string here as the function.
It looks like we've got a few sections,
including main which has some information.
Inside we finally come to this parameter 1 which has an array of
different articles about San Fransisco.
Now you'll notice here how there are spaces between the words in the response,
but that's okay.
We can actually just use this inside our URLs.
You'll notice that if right-click on one of these and click copy link address
and then paste it into my browser, we see that the spaces are replaced with %20.
When we press Enter,
we see that Wikipedia's smart enough to redirect us to San Francisco's URL.
So we create this article list variable that we set equal to the array of
articles, remember that parameter one from the object that got
returned from Wikipedia, which is the response.
And then we simply iterate through it.
Each article gets appended to the page inside a list element using an a tag, and
we simply set the URL to the URL that we create here, and it's article string,
which is the name of the article which we saw in the response.
And with that we've got a pretty awesome page.